are you surprised
that we speaking of the soviet union and
united states
and speaking of game theory are you
surprised that we haven't destroyed
ourselves with nuclear weapons yet like
that
simple formulation of mutually assured
destruction
that's a good example of an explanation
that perhaps
allows us to ask better questions but it
seems to have
actually described the reality of why we
haven't destroyed ourselves with these
ultra powerful weapons are you surprised
do you think the game theoretic
explanation is is at all accurate there
i think we will destroy each other with
those weapons
eventually eventually look it's a very
low probability
event so i'm not surprised it hasn't
happened yet i'm a little surprised it
came as close as it did
you know your general thinking realizing
it might have just been a flock of birds
or it wasn't a first strike attack from
the usa
we got very lucky on that one but if you
just keep on running the clock on a low
probability event
it will happen and it may not be usa and
china usa and russia whatever
you know it could be the saudis and
turkey and it might not be nuclear
weapons it might be some other
destruction bio weapons
but it simply will happen is my view and
i've
argued at best we have seven or eight
hundred years and that's being generous
at worst how how long we got well maybe
it's asking for
process right okay so tiny probability
could come any time
probably not in your lifetime but
uh the chance presumably increases the
cheaper
weapons of mass destruction are so the
poisson process
description doesn't take in
consideration the game theoretic aspect
so
another way to consider is uh repeated
games
iterative games so is there something
about us
our human nature that allows us to fight
against
probability uh reduce like the closer we
get to trouble
the more we're able to figure out how to
avoid trouble the same thing is
for when you take exams or you go you
know and take classes
the closer or paper deadlines the closer
you get to a deadline
the better you start to perform you get
your [ __ ] together and actually get
stuff done
i'm really not so negative on human
nature and as an economist i very much
see the gains from cooperation
yeah but if you just ask are there
outliers in history like was there a
hitler
for instance obviously and again you let
the clock tick
another hitler with nuclear weapons
doesn't per se care about
his own destruction it will happen so
your sense is fundamentally people are
good
but equilibrium is what we would call it
trembling hand equilibrium that the
basic logic
is for cooperation which is mostly what
we've seen
even between enemies but every now and
then
someone does something crazy and you
don't know how to react to it
and you can't always beat hitler
sometimes hitler drags you down
to push back is it possible that the
crazier
the person the less likely they are
and in a way where we're safe
meaning like th this is the kind of
proposition
i've had i had the discussion with my
dad as a physicist about this
where he thinks that uh uh
like if you have a graph like evil
people
can't also be geniuses so his this is
his defense why
evil people will not get control of
nuclear weapons because to be truly evil
but evil meaning sort of you can argue
that
not even the evil of hitler we're
talking about because hitler had a kind
of view of germany and all those kinds
of there's like
i he probably deluded himself and the
people around him to think that he's
actually doing good for the world
similar with stalin and so on by evil i
mean more like almost like terrorists to
where they
want to destroy themselves and the world
like those people will never be able to
be
actually skilled enough to do to deliver
that kind of
mass scale destruction so the hope is
that it's very unlikely
that the kind of evil that would lead to
extinctions of humans or
mass destruction is so unlikely
that we're able to last way longer than
seven hundred and eight hundred years
is that i agree it's very unlikely in
that sense i accept the argument
but that's why you need to let the clock
dick it's also the best argument for
bureaucracy
to negotiate a bureaucracy it actually
selects against pure evil
because you need to build alliances so
bureaucracy in that regard is great
right it keeps out
the worst apples but look put it this
way could you imagine 35 years from now
the osama bin laden of the future has
nukes or very bad bio weapons
it seems to me you can yeah and osama
was pretty evil
and actually even he failed right but
nonetheless
that's what the seven or eight hundred
years is there for and it might be
destructive technologies that don't have
such a
high cost of production or such a high
learning curve
like cyber attacks or artificial
intelligence
all those kinds of things so yeah i mean
let me ask you a question let's say you
could as an active will
by spending a million dollars obliterate
any city on earth
and everyone in it dies and you'll get
caught
and you'll be sentenced to death but you
can make it happen just by willing it
how many months does it take before that
happens
so the obvious answer is like very soon
there's probably a good answer for that
because you can
consider how many millionaires there are
how many you could look at that right
right
i have a sense that there's just people
that
have a million dollars
i mean there's a certain amount but have
a million dollars
have other interests that will outweigh
the uh the interest of destroying the
entire city
like there's a particular you know like
i mean maybe that's a hope it's why we
should be nice to the wealthy too right
[Laughter]
yeah all that trash talking is bill
gates we should stop that because uh
that doesn't inspire the other future
bill gates is to be nice to the world
it's true but your sense is the cheaper
it gets to destroy the world
the more likely it becomes now when i
say destroy the world there's a trick in
there i don't think literally every
human will die
but it would set back civilization by an
extraordinary degree it's then just
hard to predict what comes next yeah but
a catastrophe where everyone dies
that probably has to be something more
like an asteroid or a supernova
and those are purely exogenous for the
time being at least
you